Hello, PNG Ann Ferguson here.
I've got some fantastic news.
We're having our first 2024 Open Day
at our Palm Study Centre right in the centre of town on
um Saturday
February 10th from 9:00am to uh 11:00am.
It's an opportunity for parents that have missed out
their children getting
a scholarship or an offer to go to university in P N G.
Come and have a look at our state of the art facilities.
You'll be surprised to what we can offer.
As you know
we only deliver Australian accredited
programs from our study centre in palm
so make sure you come along
bring mum and dad with you kids
if uh you need to have a look at the facilities
we're gonna have special prizes on the day.
We're gonna have a reduced registration feed
to make it as absolutely affordable as possible for you
2024 all our programs are Australian
qualified and registered programs.
See you on the day.